could julianne hough be the fourth
Dancing with the Stars judge everyone
i'm denny directo with ec now according
to TMZ the pro dancers and talks return
to the reality competition show as the
fourth judge alongside Bruno carrie Ann
and Lynn Julianne served as guest judge
for the past two seasons in her most
recent stint she got into quite the tip
with dancing pro Maksim Chmerkovskiy I'm
gonna say this because i am the brutal
julie and ahem I almost felt like Max
and I'm sorry your mark this year um
I've never before I met I met I felt
like it was a little bit like you
couldn't it was like this week could get
past so that you could be back with
Marilyn you just had to phone it in so
you don't was definitely hard to carries
both thank you while Hough won't get the
chance to judge max this year as he
announced you all return for season 19
she will get the opportunity to critique
her brother and five-time winner Derek's
moves along with several new pro dancers
including Carrie Ann Inaba sex artem
chigvintsev keel Motsepe and so you
think you can dance all starr allison
hope Giuliana initially left to show
back in 2009 to pursue acting full-time
what people do have just hang out yeah
another sense and now it seems like
she'll get the best of both worlds the
judging gig will only take up a few
hours a week leaving her plenty of time
to pursue acting dancing with the stars
returns to ABC on September 15 the
celebrity contestants will be announced
on September fourth who are you hoping
to see in the ballroom let me know on
Twitter I'm at d director oh and be sure
to use the hashtag you see now